all right so we're going on holiday this
week to Lisbon and you bros coming along
let's go wow it's so nice here the
weather is amazing
so glad we went
you think that tell me heavy alright
alright alright we just arrived at the
hotel can I hold it with my shoes I'm
vlogging with my feet is not a good idea
we're gonna go out Explorer soon
hopefully it won't rain but it should be
fun let's go this guy is having a bad
day someone just trying to sell me hash
he's like you home Sweden you don't like
hash in Sweden now in Sweden we don't
like it everywhere else is fine
well I'm really glad we're skipping the
UK weather for all this thanks thanks
Lisa but hey what if we go in one of
those
okay so now we're at the oceanarium
which is really famous here in Lisbon
there's one fish that I really want to
see what is the fish column
the sunfish
let's spot some Sun look at this I think
I see a oh my god there it is
oh my god what is that thing oh my god
what the hell happened there oh my god
what is that face
I can't it's so ugly oh my god I won't
lie this is definitely me if I was a
fish
oh no not closer please oh my god no
please
look at this
they're so cute what is he doing I
wonder where all the fishes I can't see
any of them there can't be any faces
nice weather it's like rain and and Sun
at the same time we're going back to the
town because this is too crazy can't
handle a what are you doing
they're trying so hard to sell drugs
here it's so crazy we're there I told
you you would be doodly so lost without
me
good thing my hair is the best ever I
look like I'm from Dawson's Creek
ok morning we're going for breakfast and
then we're going out in the rain again
because it's celebrating but I I really
need to do my hair so did it fix my hair
but I wanted to talk about something the
car video that we did it's pretty much
going viral did I know I did not like my
own video which is awesome I don't think
I had a viral video in forever I feel
like I'm finally figuring out what I'm
doing on YouTube which is really cool
we're here at some old castle
very exciting but look at that the view
is not bad oh my god it's so windy I
feel like a nice position breath oh my
god oh my god
calm down aerobics my clinics
hi so our Lisbon train they don't really
work out as planned
it's pouring that down Oh God and it's
gonna pour down all day but it's okay
we're going for lunch hopefully we won't
be soaked by wait I can't talk it's
raining that's what I'm trying to say
the weather is nicer we're in another
city now and on top of a mountain and
this place is just insane it's so cool
it's like straight out of fairies hair
all of it we're so high up like we're
almost by the clouds I'll show you the
view in a second but it's amazing let's
make 600 tiles of the same thing yes oh
my god let's go in whoa holy [ __ ]
I feel like I'm playing Uncharted right
now oh that view man that's it oh my
gosh I have amazing 3G connection here
alright castle number two it's crazy so
this is the same region it's amazing I'm
blown away are you finding anything
interesting there's a kangaroo where oh
there is a king oh my god you're right
okay so that's the castle we just
visited a now we're gonna go to a well I
don't know what that means where Martha
keeps talking about it so I assume that
it's cool oh we better be drag me all
this way that's super creepy oh my god
what the hell oh it's dripping
everywhere oh my god oh my god its water
everywhere whoa what is this
oh okay
scare PewDiePie season 2 oh my god this
is terrifying
we're the only ones here okay let's go
here follow me
nice hat bro okay let's go what if we
get lost
it gets better here oh my god this is so
creepy
what is this oh my god I'm seeing ghosts
I'm seeing goes through the K I just saw
and PewDiePie and Marcia were never seen
again
Oh dead end if my battery runs out I am
literally dead what the [ __ ] is this
where am I going
oh it goes up
that was scary that was legit scary I
made it I'm making it oh my god wanna
jump from there I'm blown away by this
place it's so [ __ ] cool yes I will
it's like little mazes and [ __ ]
everywhere we're going now here to go to
the other place underground are you
ready for this okay
made in our life oh my god whoa holy
[ __ ] this is my shadow the Colossus oh
my god oh god you pushed me and you
scare me so much don't freakin push oh
my god this is so amazing I don't
believe it
alright are we going down look how much
water there is
okay we're down in the well oh wow that
is awesome
that is so cool
we're done exploring for today I can't
Wow what are you doing okay well this is
the Lisbon vlog thank you for coming on
today was a really fun day see chair was
awesome if you go to Lisbon and
definitely check out see Trent cuz it
was awesome
thank you for watching leave a like be
enjoyed if you want more vlogs let me
know and